foreign
hell-bent on an agenda and nothing will
change that agenda and so the jails and
the prison systems are suffering for it
hello my name is Chad Bianco and I am
the sheriff of Riverside County
our society in general has not changed I
we we have not become more criminal as a
society there there are I don't believe
there are more criminals in society than
there were 20 30 40 50 years ago uh
criminality is is and always has been a
very small portion of our population it
and I and who knows what those numbers
are for round numbers say five percent
so 95 percent of the the people in
public are great good people and the
other five percent are criminals and we
have to stop treating them as anything
different than criminals because
everyone can make a mistake but when you
make that mistake you get slapped on the
wrist and you change your behavior the
true criminal doesn't care about the
consequences they don't care if they're
going to jail they don't care if they're
getting probation they don't care if
they go to prison and those people have
never changed uh the percentage of
people
as we started with ab109 when we just
decided to let hardened
career criminals out of prison not send
them to prison anymore and put them in
County jails where we are not set up to
house long-term prisoners that was the
start of of really I don't want to say a
failure but of the of the severe decline
in our uh ability to house prisoners and
to house criminals
yes the state of the California prison
system is in in my opinion complete
disarray and all because of our governor
uh he is he is going against what real
experts say uh he has an agenda to close
prisons and there is nothing going to
stop him from doing that and the only
way you close prisons is you stop crime
stop people from committing crime or let
them out
that's all that can happen because
they've been sentenced to a determinate
time in prison
if they serve that time they're stuck in
prison so he's decided that he's going
to change the time that they're in
prison and he lets them out early he's
let thousands and thousands of criminals
hardened criminals out early we actually
got three requests in Riverside County
for that he is he is notifying US unless
we provide compelling information that
he is going to release murders three
murderers that are in prison for murder
they're supposed to be there for life
and he is going to release them
back into our community so that is what
the governor is doing with
our prisons he's just randomly releasing
people that shouldn't be released and
then the lawmakers and the courts are
stopping people from going to prison
anymore
so our prisons are being drawn down in
numbers and then they consolidate those
inmates into other prisons and then
close those prisons everyone knows that
that's the wrong thing to do for the
prison system and it's the wrong thing
to do for our general law-abiding public
who
all you have to do is look out the
window and see that we're being
victimized constantly
it goes back to this this very very big
push we have had
um about the LIE of mass incarceration
uh I want to make that perfectly clear
to everyone that is a complete lie there
is no such thing as mass incarceration
uh it's a play on words it's a play on
your emotions and it does not exist it's
a lie from that agenda that the people
pushing that agenda to try and get you
to to come alongside them and and feel
what they what they think
the the answer for our crime and the
answer for our our overcrowding in our
prison system is build more prisons the
population of California has steadily
increased
I talked earlier about the five percent
that of the population that that is
criminal that you're never going to
change as the the general population
increases
naturally that five percent has to
increase also because it gets that five
percent becomes more and more people
Common Sense would tell you you're going
to need more prisons and more jails to
house those those criminals as their
numbers increase and what we are doing
is eliminating those beds those prison
cells and basically the people are
committing crimes and staying out in the
in the streets and committing more
crimes the amount of repeat offenders
right now is just ridiculous
um we we unfortunately in the last year
we've seen three Law Enforcement
Officers be killed by career criminals
that should not have been out of custody
they should have been in prison and
three Law Enforcement Officers lost
their lives and
other people there are other victims
also they're victimizing other people
they're killing other people they're
they're they're they're they're stealing
from other people
and it's something that our lawmakers
and our governor just refuse to
acknowledge they are bent hell-bent on
an agenda and nothing will change that
agenda and so the jails and the prison
systems are suffering for it